[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima on what is  arguably the best episode of Nick vile  season of The Bachelor  yet Corinne and Taylor went head-to-head  emotional intelligence is a really  important thing in a relationship she  flat-out asked me what is the notional  intelligence talking about you dumb  [ __ ] yes who is emotionally intelligent  and who is the B word well Corinne ended  up getting the rose at the end of there  by you two-on-one  but Taylor pulled kind of a Chad Johnson  and came back we were left with a to be  continued so that's up in the air but  one thing that is confirmed  Raven dropped the l-bomb to Nick  actually the moment I fell in love with  you is they hang the little mermaids too  soon but I said it whatever I own it  hey it's not too much too soon when you  own it right what did you guys think of  Ravens confession and do you think  Taylor should get another chance let me  know over on Twitter  [Music]  you